more than 70 cases of a new coronavirus
variant have been discovered in the uk
officials say the strain first detected
in india is
under investigation rather than a
variant of concern like the brazil or
south africa mutations
the majority of the infections are in
england while a small number
were found in scotland well joining me
now from edinburgh is professor linda
bald she's chair of public health at the
university of edinburgh's
usher institute um thank you so much for
um
talking to us so a variant under under
investigation
when does it move to a variant of
concern and what determines that move
well this is the b1617 we actually don't
know as much about it kimberly as we
would like to
in maharashtra which is a state of india
that's been badly affected it has the
highest number of
of cases of any indian states at the
moment the latest sequencing suggests it
accounts for about 61
of their cases and it seems to have two
mutations to the spike protein
and there's concerns that it may evade
part of the body's
immune response but we don't know that
so what what what happens when it
becomes more on the alert list it means
that we need more information
both from scientists in india and also
we'll have scientists here in the uk
looking very
closely at those 77 cases those early
days
but i think as we've learned throughout
this pandemic where you have countries
or settings where you have a large
number of cases high incidence and
prevalence in the disease
gives these mutations variations and an
opportunity to develop
and and that's why we really want to
keep an eye on this and try and not have
more of these in the uk when was it
first identified in india
in march and so sequencing and there's
there is
good there is sequencing capacity in
india so it's been identified for a
while now but i think
what's happened as with the kent varian
if you remember the kent variant was
actually identified first in september
and it wasn't really until november was
it that we started to hear more about it
in december when the alert was really
raised because those cases were rising
in kent despite restrictions being in
place
similar things happening in india now
we're seeing that
the surge in cases particularly in some
states is so significant it had over 200
000 cases yesterday in india and young
people in hospital
so we've known about it for a while our
colleagues there have but it's really
the effect that we're now beginning to
see that's causing real
worry the death rate is also up sunday
839 deaths in india they haven't had
a very high death rate if you look at
the population
in total but do they think that this new
variant
is playing into that death rate as well
they think so so just to emphasize
there's no evidence yet
that this is causing more disease
severity but if it's more transmissible
as we've seen with the other variants
then you are going to impact the number
of people who go into hospital
and mortality so i was speaking to a
colleague in india this morning they are
incredibly concerned
about the age profile of some of the
patients they're seeing in hospital
and in some of the states the capacity
particularly for ventilation
is really being challenged at the moment
so it's just the sheer
volume so more transmissible variants
mean more people become unwell
and that really challenges the
healthcare system and i think it's just
a reminder to everybody in the uk that
globally
this pandemic is actually accelerating
in some countries while we're here
easing restrictions so very much a
cautionary tale as i said
and yet we have 77 cases here that we
know of i mean how concerned should we
be
that we are easing restrictions here and
we're getting new variants in
i think it is a reminder to us of a
fragile situation and the surge testing
in london for the b1351 the south
african variant again
i'm hoping that you know that will not
lead to many more cases and even local
restrictions having to be applied that's
a scenario we want to avoid but as we
open up
as everybody has been saying on your
program and others we have to keep an
eye on what's happening internationally
and have a grown-up conversation about
our borders and international
travel now unless something's changed in
the last few hours india unlike
bangladesh and pakistan
is not on the red list i think there are
real questions about that we don't want
any countries to be on that list but it
is about protecting the progress
actually
that we've made do you think that's the
only way to actually stop a variant from
spreading in the country
is that if everyone who comes in from a
country where we know that that variant
is prevalent
has to go into a hotel
where we can monitor what they're doing
it's a key part of the response i know
this is deeply unpopular
and but it is what has been tried and
tested in australia new zealand
southeast asian countries is managed
quarantine
and we do need to apply that also we
just need two other things briefly
kimberly we need the sequencing which we
have in the uk and we're
now able to sequence many more of the
proportion of cases because cases are
less
and we need the support for
self-isolation that people are
identified with any variants in the
community
and there are still questions around
that but yes manage quarantine
i think for some countries is something
we are going to have to continue
to really have in the uk to get on top
of this issue briefly should india be
put on the red list and should it be put
on
immediately without some sort of a
lead-in time
well i'm not making any of the policy
decisions and i try and
stick to the science and underline what
we know but in terms of an effective
intervention that might make a
difference
manage quarantine and restricting travel
hopefully temporarily is as i say a
tried and tested approach used in other
countries
professor bald thank you so much